this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream get free access to
nebula the new streaming platform built
by and for creators when you sign up for
curiosity stream at the link below on
[Music]
May 30th 2020 SpaceX made history by
becoming the first private company to
launch NASA astronauts into space the
launch was a culmination of years of
preparation and development and despite
having to postpone the launch due to
weather when the Falcon 9 rocket lifted
off the ground that Saturday it
performed admirably and the two
astronauts aboard the crew capsule
safely made their way towards the ISS as
groundbreaking as this moment was it
does raise some serious questions about
the future of space flight and space
industry in this episode we're going to
take a look at past legislation
regarding the ownership of space and how
private companies can cooperate with the
world's nations to build a brighter
future for everyone let's start with a
little background in the late 1950s and
continuing through the 1960s the US and
the Soviet Union were slugging it out
trying to establish superiority in the
new realm of outer space both
superpowers feared the other becoming
dominant and placing new types of
weapons in Earth orbit becoming even
more dangerous to each other and the
rest of the world after a very tense
period of international competition the
US UK and the Soviet Union came together
and signed what's informally known as
the outer space treaty this document was
the first of its kind and attempted to
establish a basis for international
space law today over a hundred countries
are party to the treaty with over 20
more working towards ratification at its
core the outer space treaty is a
non-nuclear agreement it doesn't
prohibit military activities in space
nor even the placement of conventional
weapons but it does explicitly ban the
use of weapons of mass destruction it
also stipulates that space and celestial
bodies must be free to explore by all
nations and that no party may lay claim
to any region of space or celestial body
this is all well and good but the
problem with the outer space treaty is
that it was drafted back in the 1960s
when our understanding of space was
considerably more limited than it is
today which means much of the language
was left fairly ambiguous fast forward
to more recent years and we've learned
that asteroids are often full of
incredibly valuable resources and that
we might be able to mine them there are
even some reports to suggest a
particular asteroid could be worth
upwards of 20 trillion dollars that's
one way to get the attention of large
corporations and eccentric billionaires
like Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos and
conveniently the Outer Space Treaty
doesn't explicitly say you can't extract
celestial resources as long as you don't
claim the area from which you're
extracting them but just to be safe the
u.s. passed the Space Act of 2015 which
clarified the country's position on
their rights in outer space the law
explicitly allows US citizens and
corporations to engage in the commercial
exploration and exploitation of space
resources including water and minerals
as some of the world's richest
individuals suit up to build their own
space resource extraction operations we
should look back to a forgotten episode
of the early days of space exploration
back in the 1960s a group of
underdeveloped nations banded together
to form a coalition known as the group
of 77 this group used the strength of
their numbers among UN nations to try to
influence international space law to
prevent it from disproportionately
benefiting the world's wealthiest
countries their goal was a more
equitable distribution of profits
derived from outer space resources they
believed that space was the common
heritage of all humankind
and as such should be utilized to
benefit the entire human population and
to help fund underdeveloped nations
rather than let extraordinary wealth
pile up in the hands of a few powerful
countries the group of 77 understood the
language of the outer space treaty to
call for a new economic order that would
reduce global poverty and increase the
well-being of all nations the treaty
says the exploration and use of outer
space shall be carried out for the
benefit and in the interest of all
countries irrespective of their degree
of economic or scientific development
and shall be the province of all mankind
in 1971 delegate to the Committee on the
peaceful uses of outer space proposed a
new legal designation for the final
frontier that of the common heritage of
mankind this was a fairly new idea
originally applied to maritime law just
a few years earlier if space were given
this designation it would lend legal
support for the Democratic distribution
of revenues derived from outer space in
1973 the group officially called for an
amendment to the Outer Space Treaty to
include the common heritage language one
delegate neatly summed up the group's
position saying it does not seem
justifiable that space activities should
evolve in a climate of total
laissez-faire which would conceal under
the cloak of rationality new ways for an
abusive exercise of power by those who
exert control over technology
despite pushback from both the US and
the Soviet Union not to mention a horde
of angry businessmen the final version
of the draft did include the common
heritage language
1979 when the amendment came up for
ratification it was met with intense
opposition including pushback from the
Reagan administration and eventually the
group had to abandon it another group
made a similar attempt in 1988 and was
also forced into submission by 1996 the
United States had clarified their stance
on the benefit clause ii mean vague
assurances of helping underdeveloped
nations build their own space technology
the final word from the UN outer space
committee came in 2014 when they put out
an article summarizing their recent
meeting its headline read outer space
benefits must not be allowed to widen
global gap between economic social
inequality fourth committee told and
that was that they paid lip service to
the past efforts of their members but
embraced the position of equal access
instead of democratic accountability and
distribution returning to today we're
nearing the end of our opportunity to
ensure space industry is democratically
regulated what we're facing is not just
a new era of space exploration it's
essentially the handing of a key to an
inaccessible realm to the world's
richest people if smaller nations and
individuals from around the world speak
up now we could make a real difference
here at the beginning of a new era it's
not just national bragging rights that
are at stake
it's a political and economic struggle
over the very nature of the celestial
Commons there are two possible outcomes
the massive intensification of
inequality or the potential for the
elevation of all people and a movement
towards an egalitarian world if
billionaires and soon-to-be trillionaire
--zz like Jeff Bezos are allowed to
transcend even the resource limits of
the earth and access cosmic resources
beyond the reach of the entirety of
mankind they will amass godlike power
the shear dollar value of off earth
resources is simply unfathomable in the
repercussions of allowing all that
wealth to flow into the bank accounts of
a handful of ultra wealthy and powerful
people would have disastrous effects
instead of buying yachts football teams
and private islands space industrialists
could buy entire nations this capitalist
techno utopia would look less like star
trek and more like altered carbon with
those who benefit from space industry
physically separated from the unwashed
masses and completely above the law and
any repercussions for their actions
space should be considered the common
heritage of all of humanity like
Alaska's sovereign wealth fund which
delivers a percentage of oil revenue to
its residents the same could be done for
the inhabitants of planet Earth
yes compensate the companies in
solved in the extraction but distribute
the wealth in a manner that reflects a
democratic vision of outer space if we
choose to see the space beyond earth as
an International Commons it would give
us a fantastic opportunity to experiment
with redistribute of mechanisms beyond
the usual confines of nation-states if
we can think big picture and establish a
sovereign wealth fund for the entire
earth imagine what that could do for our
species and the planet as space resource
extraction grows and becomes a more
profitable industry redistribution of
the revenue could create a genuine
global universal basic income freeing
citizens the world over from crippling
poverty elevating developing nations and
furthering the advancement of the entire
species the windfall from space industry
could allow nations to invest in clean
energy public works programs education
and their own space programs easing the
burden on the already existing ones a
super abundance of resources like
platinum that are scarce here on earth
could potentially allow for an expansion
of automation to the extent that output
is dramatically increased in the need
for human labour reduced allowing all
people more time to spend with their
loved ones and pursue things like the
arts which benefit everyone there's
nothing wrong with making money from
space resources as long as that money is
distributed equitably now is the time to
start talking about the democratization
about her space either it benefits
everyone or we're headed for a dystopia
of inequality we cannot yet begin to
fathom outer space shouldn't be about
flag-waving and conquest but about the
expansion of human potential beyond the
bounds of earth in a way that elevates
all of us if you'd like to learn more
about some of the upcoming private space
missions I highly recommend you check
out packing for Mars on curiosity stream
it's a fascinating look at all the
challenges involved in landing humans on
the red planet if you watch my videos
you'll know I'm a big fan of curiosity
stream it's an online streaming service
with thousands of nonfiction titles from
some of the best filmmakers in the game
you can find tons of great episodes like
packing for Mars and they've got a bunch
of material on technology and outer
space which are some of my favorites
they're giant catalogue includes content
on science nature astronomy technology
and lifestyle among others curiosity
stream has always supported independent
content creators so they've partnered
with nebula the streaming platform built
by a bunch of your favorite youtubers
including me nebula is a place for us to
try new things and make original content
that just wouldn't be possible on
YouTube it's a home for all of your
favorite creators outside of YouTube and
there's a ton of cool original
tent already there with more on the way
you can get unlimited access to both
curiosity stream and nebula for just 20
bucks a year that's less than two
dollars a month and it really does help
me create more content like this give
curiosity stream a shot visit curiosity
stream comm slash second thought if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to see
more like it consider subscribing to
stay up to date with my latest episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down and if you really want to
help support my channel I recently
started a patreon which you can find at
patreon.com slash second thought you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen thanks
for watching and I'll see you next week